all right let's do this
[Music]
all right ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to your absolutely favorite
podcast
you know the name
[Music]
welcome back
[Music]
all right y'all welcome back
[Music]
all right that's all we gonna do with
our theme song
you know why because i'm recording kind
of late so
it is what it is um anyways uh thanks
for being back here with riffing with
griffin
riffin with griffin
um i don't even know what to say uh
weird week um anyways
let me just do all the the business
stuff just like i said thank you for
listening and subscribing and remember
if you
want to watch me game my game every week
every day
on twitch eric griffin gaming and then
you can see those videos there griffin
gaming on youtube also so i appreciate
the support that i've gotten there
a lot of great stuff has happened
because of the gaming and i'm like i'm
hosting a new show
that's coming out on twitch on the crown
channel it's called potluck
um but let me get all the information
for you because it's like some fun stuff
that's going on there
um yes potluck
yeah and i'm i'm hosting the show
uh what's it called
wait yeah with uh it's me and
lisa i wanted to get lisa's last name
correct
malambri malambri my lambre i don't know
if that's how i serenade but it's lee
i just know it's lisa so me and lisa
we're hosting this show
it's called potluck it starts on 12
uh december 9th and we're just going to
be you know
exploring all the weird stuff that goes
on on twitch
you know all the different things you
know the other things just gaming
there's a lot of actually weird things
like how to
there's a lot of like asmr there's a lot
so we're gonna be exploring all those
things so make sure you check that out
it's gonna be on the crown channel
uh twitch crown channel so anyways uh so
that's
what i got coming up and that's all from
the gaming stuff too just for me being a
part of the gaming world i getting all
these opportunities so that's great
so um first i want to say last week i
was talking about
uh buying a house and not buying a house
versus renting and all this kind of
stuff and i got an overwhelming response
like
so many people hit me up talking about
giving me their two cents most of the
the
the things that i got back were actually
really great like you know
some were like real estate experts some
financial experts some people agreed
with some of the things that i was
saying but the consensus was
buy a house is a good investment which i
all which i i want to do that's that is
the ultimate plan i you know i
i live in la and having a house it would
be great but
i just want to point out to some of you
that you don't understand the whole
thing you know i can't just buy a house
like
me personally uh i have money in the
bank because i'm a frugal guy
and you know i've been on tv and i've
you know with the bulk of the money that
i've made from different things i i've
saved it and i've invested it and i've
had it because
i don't know if i'm a work again that's
just how i feel all the time after every
show ends you don't know are you going
to get on another show is it
other things going to happen you know
and i'm not rich by any stretch of
imagination you know what you might
think you see people on tv you think
well they must have a lot of money
you see my kitchen on my kitchen with
griffin episodes i got a little kitchen
you know so
yes you want to buy a house but you have
to understand something when you're in
the entertainment business
the most like there's only a small
percentage of people in an entertainment
business who are say millionaires who
make like so much money that it doesn't
matter they could just buy a house
outright
i'm not one of those people so i live in
la and i'm not married i'm engaged but
we're not married yet
and it's not even like what rachel does
is enough
for a bank to be like okay we're going
to give you 800
000 because first of all you know i want
to buy a nice house so so do i want to
buy a million dollar house probably
right but if you know the la housing
market that ain't even a nice house
it could be a nice condo it depends on
the neighborhood that you live in and
where you want to live and stay so if i
want to be in la and i want to be on the
west side
who knows you know anyways my point is
trying to tell you is
when you you have to go to the bank and
get a loan
so i'm you know i have money for a down
payment so let's say i put down two
hundred thousand three hundred thousand
dollars
so i gotta get some kind of like seven
hundred thousand eight hundred thousand
dollar loan
right the bank is not going to give
somebody a loan
that can't prove they're going to have
steady income
that's the downside of being like an
independent contractor
uh you know you're if you're a salaried
employee you have a job and you know
they're more inclined to be like well
this person has proof that they have
income coming in every month for me
like i'm the comedy business shut down
you know hollywood is just coming back
but i'm not on a show you know like if i
already
i know this the next show i get on if i
get on the show
knock on wood knock on potato head
i if i get a show i have a contract
that's going to be my time to be like
all right you go to the bank
look i'm going to be on this show it's
going 10 episodes 20 episodes
it's the second season i have this
amount of money i want to purchase a
house
it is actually not as easy as you guys
think so everybody's hitting me up with
their advice and their thoughts and like
what's good or bad but
you have to understand that there's more
to it than just what you think you know
you have to
this you know ever since the 2008 crash
and the loan they were just giving out
loans willy-nilly
they no longer do that they're very
cautious about who they give loans to
when they give loans how much they give
loans
you know um they they delve into your
life they want to really make sure that
okay well can you pay
for 25 years are you going to be able to
pay this mortgage payment you know it's
it's very
it's a whole complicated process so when
in that time
you know i rent
you know what i mean maybe i should have
bought something from before but i just
i travel so much i was mostly a bachelor
i was like what am i doing
you know who knows if that was the right
decision or not but hey i'm okay with it
you know what i mean yeah i i i have all
my money
you know what i mean so it's like maybe
it could be worth more but money that i
can't even get
like it's like yes if you buy a house
and you and it increases in value
you're like look how much much more i'm
worth then maybe you know you borrow
against that and that's how you get the
money
but for me like you know i have the
money i i always
i just was like cautious i never knew if
if i never work again how am i gonna pay
my bills and live
so i always thought i need to have this
money you know that's just my thought
but
again i do appreciate all of the
comments all of the
uh the message i really got some really
detailed messages from people
like you know i'm a financial expert and
this is my two cents and you know it was
really it's really nice i really like
the interaction that i get from
you guys some of it's bad i mean they're
just a small possession unfortunately
the the bad ones the really like
ignorant rude
people that send like these messages
because they have they obviously
just they they don't know how to have a
conversation with someone without being
a [ __ ]
there's quite a few of those too but you
know we won't go into that you know
you know who you are you know you know
what i mean so it's just those people so
like i say i do thank everybody that
sent me messages about that and this is
something to think about i did i did
find a place
you know because i want to move and i
found this place and
rachel likes it i i liked it too as soon
as i saw the thing i was like oh i
really like this place you know
that i wanted to move to but then it
would turn into this thing where it was
like
again even at this place they were like
well you know in this
day and age you're like well can you pay
this rent you know so then i had to like
show them well this is the money having
the bank and then the guy was like well
we want
well can you pay three months ahead of
time six months ahead of time you know
it's like
it turns into a whole thing you know so
it's not as easy as you think even when
you have
some money you know what i mean the
world is weird right now
but anyways i thank everybody for uh the
messages
the other thing is like again once again
we had this whole chronovirus
you know thing and i don't want to go
into too much about it but one thing
that i did
talk about before i think it was last
week that i said you know
you know does the coronal virus
affect people and i was
using the nfl players like ezekiel
elliott and
cam newton from the patriots ziggler
plays for dallas
and cam newton himself this past few
days he came out and said
he was like i gotta be honest i haven't
been right since i had the coronavirus
you know to me that is what needs to be
talked about more than showing death
totals
you know like just showing that people
die because people die
from the flu every single year i mean a
large number of people
every single year die from the flu
nobody talks about it because we just
kind of go
this part of our life it's like okay
well what's the you know it's just a
bunch of numbers that people don't even
we can't even wrap our brains around and
this is what i've always been saying is
like
how you use these death numbers you know
so anyways cam newton comes out and he
says yeah this has affected me i've been
foggy
and he couldn't make this the right snap
decisions
so now he's finally saying that now he's
starting to feel more himself
so that's the kind of thing that makes
the coronavirus scary
you know obviously nobody wants to die
right
but you know when you have something
that has a one percent death rate okay
less than one percent people die from
this and the people that do die are
people with
most majority of them have pre-existing
conditions or they're over a certain age
so when you have those kind of figures
you kind of go well how does this affect
me because that's really what the
problem is about this right now
is how it affects people and everybody
has their own
individual experience look there's some
people out there who have family members
and friends who have died who have
say gone into a coma or they've had some
really severe
um side effects from having corona
and they really struggled but most of us
don't know someone like that
you know we just we don't know someone
like that so we looked at look at that
as an isolated incident look
if it was like 50 percent of the people
that get this die
this it would be completely different
reaction if it was a situation where we
all knew someone
who died or we knew someone that had
some really severe condition it would be
different but that's not what's
happening you know what i mean
so it's hard to like we all live in our
own bubbles and we're just trying to be
like hey
you know so like you know and i keep
talking about this and i keep getting
these messages from people that like are
misquoting me
they you know they keep they you know
they want to take a piece of
what i'm saying and then use that to to
hear themselves talk or to like you know
to be on the internet like oh i want to
say that
why don't you understand you know listen
guys look i want to say this again for
the last
[ __ ] time okay i'm cursing
because that's how pissed off i am about
it
i've talked about this now for weeks i
am not comparing
one deaths to the other i never was
doing that
i'm just again talking about how
we use numbers to push our point forward
okay is it
why is it wrong to
ask the question how we are
handling and dealing the coronavirus how
do we
justify it to everyone
with a death rate less than one percent
now
am i saying i don't believe it's a hoax
like i'm not one of those people i want
us to be safe i
agree with everybody wearing masks i
agree with like social distancing and
all these kinds of things
what i'm saying to you is if you're one
of these people who is just adamant
about
you know we need to shut the whole
country down and
you know and by the way it's a lot of
rich people talking about this too that
i can't say i even have friends who are
tweeting about it
if we just stay indoors for two months
we could you know hit this curve
it's like yeah easy for you to say you
live in a mansion you know what i mean
easy for you to say because you don't
have to worry
about money but there are people out
here that have to worry about their
bills getting paid and
and their restaurants closing down and
they're businesses that have been you
know they've been in business for years
and now they can never open again
they're going in foreclosure i mean all
the financial repercussions of what
we've done
is it's it's uh it's very heavy you know
but
i'm asking you can you justify it
is is it wrong to ask that question how
do we
justify shutting down the economy
shutting down the country when you look
at these numbers
and you go okay so you know these are a
lot of deaths
i get that but there are a lot of deaths
in a lot of different areas of
of the society that you know we have
we deal with so can we have a
conversation
where we're just asking how do you
justify because it's more nuanced than
just somebody
who because first of all y'all not
doctors neither am i
you people that are hitting me up you
know you're hitting me up like
you're mad at me like why don't you la
comedians understand how severe
like what do you know you you don't know
anything you're getting your information
from twitter
you know listen we have to really
it is so much more a bigger issue this
conversation i'm saying that we should
have
i don't think we are handling the
coronavirus correctly
i don't think we've handled it correctly
from the beginning and and there's a lot
of reasons for that
you know you have the national you know
the leaders of the government you know
you had the trump administration
saying one thing you had leaving it up
to the states and every state has their
own opinion about what they should do
it became political so you know you had
you know we weren't handling it
collectively like this is what we should
do we were left to our own devices
and so here we are in this situation
look you can't
if listen just justify it
i i was on fighting the kid and i'm just
asking the question
is it wrong to question to want to
understand how we justifying
shutting down the country when you look
at the numbers
of what's happening with the coronavirus
so now
like the chronovirus um cases are they
seem to be rising they're spiking we're
getting more and more people
because i think that more people think
about it the way i'm saying
because you know and and i'm not saying
that's the right way to think about it
when they're just using a little bit of
it they're just saying look it doesn't
seem like i know anybody like
if you're a person that's like well i
don't think anybody i know has gotten it
i don't think it's that serious it seems
to me that it's just like a cold
and you're just going on with your life
you're like well why am i shutting down
why am i i have to work
you know so you you know your thought
process goes that way and you're just
like well whatever
so then people are gonna get it they
think like that
and you know so if you're gonna talk to
me
and we're gonna talk you know have a
conversation or back and forth
it's a it's a legitimate concern a
legitimate question to ask
can we justify what we've been doing or
what we want to do
based off what we know
right now i
i don't understand why that's so
difficult i don't understand why i'm
being attacked
because i'm asking you can you justify
these
there's people out there that have lost
their job there's people out there that
are like
you know the drug use is up suicide is
up
you know people people have lost their
businesses that have gone on there's
there's you know
the small theaters are going under just
in my business alone you know
all these theaters and all the art
programs and all these like places that
you know provide uh entertainment
they're shut down all the people that
worked there all
like it's all of these things and we go
damn
if you're saying if you want to say hey
the coronavirus is so dangerous
and it is so contagious
that no matter what happens to people
financially
we have to continue to go this way
if that's how you feel then just say
that
but the other side might be asking
how do you justify that based off the
numbers
uh is that wrong to ask
i don't i don't get that like can we
just have an honest conversation about
it
no people just get like so fired up and
they just
you know they they wanna then they
attack you personally and you just go
well
we're not even having a conversation
right now people get their information
from the facebook and twitter and
you know getting getting solid
information getting information from
twitter
is like getting medical medical
information from
grey's anatomy you know it looks right
they're using the right words
uh it's pretty but it's not real
you know so i don't know what we're
gonna do
i really don't i don't know what we're
gonna do but i'm telling you right now
it's gonna get to a head where people
are gonna take this risk reward
assessment
and they're not gonna stop like people
are not just gonna be like
all right okay well we're just gonna you
know we're gonna stay home and we're not
gonna do anything
i mean i think we're beyond that at this
point now how are we gonna manage what's
happening in the world
hopefully if like biden gets into office
you know he will
make have a national mandate like this
is what we're going to do as a nation
because i think that's what
was needed in that particular case you
know it's just weird and then we still
have this thing about you know
is trump gonna leave he's not conceding
and we have all these things and it's so
polarizing because everybody lives in an
echo chamber man
everybody does you know it's like i have
some friends that are so liberal that
they just don't want to hear or see
anything like if you
because first of all 71 million people
voted for trump so
you all know a trump supporter and maybe
they're quiet because they don't want to
be like oh i don't want to say anything
because
everybody hates this guy um you know
listen
everybody takes a risk reward you know
if you're somebody that was like look
i don't necessarily like the man i
didn't like the things he was saying
you know he didn't carry himself a
certain way but you're like
but i did like the policies i liked uh
the things he did
with foreign policy i like the things he
did with the finances i like the things
he did with like you know
like with ice cube we're talking you
know you know
he went to the ice cube went to because
he's getting all this flack but he you
know
it's about the black caucus so it was
some kind of i forgot exactly what it
was you know but
it was something to do with black people
and the trump administration was like
yeah let's talk about it you know so he
was like okay
so what i'm saying is you know it can
you separate
your feelings about him and the things
that he says it does his behavior
and all that can you separate that from
the deeds
you know it's a tough thing you know we
do that for music we do that you know
if somebody does something horrible you
know if somebody
beats somebody up or you know has some
accusations but we go home the guy makes
really good music
i think trump i think for some people it
was like that with trump
i think some of the people that voted
for trump said in their mind
you know of the here's 10 things about
him
uh four of them are terrible but these
other six i can
i can live with these four because these
other six and you people that hate trump
and you people that want to talk racism
and you people want to say all these
things all the time
you ha you have there's nothing in you
to be like
are these six things important to people
are those six things that went well
are those things that they that the
people think went well for them
they're not important enough for you but
then you don't even want to have a
conversation with them and you want to
just ridicule them
i think that's unfair i think it's
unfair
but you need to you know this wasn't a
mandate you need to really look at
yourself
this was the most votes in the history
okay
you know biden won the popular vote by a
huge margin like 7
million people is a lot but it's not a
lot when you consider
that means over a like it was like over
150 million people voted or something
like that it's like it was an
astronomical number so everybody came
out and voted right
so you can't discount these people that
believe in
republican beliefs uh you know you can't
discount those people you can't just
you know oh they're crazy they're stupid
they don't understand
you know they don't care about what you
know it's not it's not just about that
you know you we need to just take a
breath and have a conversation and like
you need to find a trump supporter and
be like hey why did you vote for trump
and then hear what they have to say and
then then after you hear what they have
to say then you can go well you know
this is what i feel but can there can we
find some common ground
it's just it's it's so it's terrible
i just think it's terrible me personally
i voted for biden because
of i don't like anytime there's a leader
in office and there's like a huge
division there's a huge
polarizing polarizing division
in the country i always looked at it as
like that that's bad leadership
i just don't like that yeah and it just
was just it's
just so you know and then and what he's
doing right now i think is just
disgraceful you know you have these
these lawsuits that are all
they're just getting thrown out all over
the place but the misinformation about
it him coming out and saying look i won
there's there's this like widespread
conspiracy like saying that kind of
stuff it
undermines our democracy it undermines
the system and so
and and i and and he has been like that
regardless of the good things like
financially loved the guy it was great
you know stock market was booming i
liked some i like
some of his foreign policy things that
he had the way he handled some things
i liked what he said about minimum wage
i mean there were some things like
okay well the guy is he's not a you know
he's not completing income poop you know
what i mean
uh you know it's just i just like how he
handled himself in some areas you know
like when he talked about the taxes and
he said you know yeah i didn't want to
pay taxes who wants to pay taxes you
know i used the loopholes that they had
in place and i took advantage of them
you know these are loopholes that have
been in place when democrats have been
in office you've been the president
you know these democrats are talking
about hey you didn't pay your taxes it's
like yeah because
you have it set up well you don't have
to you know you mad at the guy because
he took advantage of that so i mean
there's a lot of things where you go
you know anyways the point is can you
have a conversation
so you know i really do recommend like
if you're someone that's just like
you're one of these people that you just
hate trump and you're just like he's a
racist he's a misogynist and you have
all these things you want to say about
him
that actually have nothing to do with
you know
uh him doing his job you know i'm not
saying that that's
right i'm not saying that that's right
but that's
what someone voting thinks about you
know
they're thinking about how does this
affect me in my life in my community
uh you know his things he does in his
personal life and things that he says
does it affect me and my community
some people some people feel like no it
doesn't other people feel like no he
can't say that it's a detriment i mean
you know you know what i'm saying
there's like there's both sides so it's
important to
communicate i just think it's important
to find people that
you know you don't you don't necessarily
agree with them
but it's more layered than just being
like he's a racist and so that's why he
has to go
even though that's a great reason if he
really is racist
that's a great reason for him to go you
know i agree with that
but i'm saying this is the reality of
the world that we live in
you know politicians are politicians uh
you know they they're two-faced they lie
uh because they have to secure votes and
and it's just a very complicated job and
you know we are the people
we think we understand but we really
don't so it doesn't help that you're
fighting with someone that you might
know that's a friend of yours a family
member
who is like well this is why i voted for
trump and it might be flimsy
it could just be like well i just like
his how he dealt with the economy and
you're
willing to ignore all all the other
things that you might come and say well
he did this
but you know you might end up at a
stalemate and it's important just to
communicate and talk about all these
things and the same thing with the
coronavirus it's important just to talk
about stuff
you know what i mean it's like if you
just ask the question people think
you're crazy
people think you don't understand like
yeah i'm not a i'm not a denier i wear a
mask i i try to be socially distant i
try to stay home i try
you know i'm doing all the things that i
feel that you should do
but you're mad at me that i want to ask
the damn question of like
yo like is are we handling this the
right way
that's really the question are we
handling this the right way
you know based off the numbers too just
based off the numbers if i'm just
being a common sense person i can look
at these numbers and go you go
somebody said to me hey we're gonna this
is we're gonna shut down the economy
we're gonna we're gonna make make it so
people you know
businesses that rely on being indoors
we're gonna just shut them down for uh
for nine months you know we're gonna
shut them down for nine months
uh because this
virus is going around and less than one
percent
people die from it can you justify that
i just i just want that that's the that
what i'm saying is that's a fair
question and if your response is
you come back with a response it's like
well yes because
you know it's con it's a contagious
disease it goes
this you know what you know it causes
these amount of problems i mean you know
i just
i'm waiting to hear the response you
know i don't i never get the proper
response i just get attacked you know
and i just i can't stand that
people still attacking me about i said
listen like just one idiot on the
internet you know i shouldn't even give
this
stupid [ __ ] any any more than you
know but it's like
i wasn't comparing smoking deaths
to coronavirus what i was saying
is again for the third week in a row how
we use
numbers to push information forward
that's it there are so many things that
cause
deaths in our country and we those
numbers aren't on cnn on the board
and maybe they should be is my point my
point if we really want to stop smoking
deaths like one idiot said to me
look it's not the same because smoking
doesn't affect people for 10 years
so that just tells me that if 400 000
people a year are dying from smoking
and this goes back 10 years we haven't
been handling that right either
like how stupid is that if you think
about it like how
it just it's like people want to push
their point forward
and the things that they say are so
stupid to push their point forward
when all i'm trying to say is let's have
a
conversation so we can all
understand the choices that we're making
so we can come together
and handle this way better than we have
is that all right with you guys all
right
enough of that um you know somebody hit
me with a great message like sometimes
like i said people
send me things and i hear them and it
really gets to me i go oh this guy's
right
so i've been on steve lee's podcast my
buddy steve
you know we and i said to steve steve
does all these things where he'll like
he'll he'll do cooking he'll do unboxing
he'll do like
man on the street and i remember saying
to him like instead of doing them all
separate man
you should put them all together and
have like the steve lee variety show the
stevie webby [ __ ] right i gave him that
advice
and then here i am separating my [ __ ]
like i did my
grown man advice segment like completely
separate
and then i thought about it later i was
like i didn't somebody hit me up like
why did you why are you doing that and
you're giving steve that advice
and you're so 100 correct so
now i'm back i'm gonna be doing i have a
whole slew of questions from people for
real world advice from a grown-ass man
and i'm going to be keeping it together
in the show along with having rachel on
the show
and then maybe i'll just do two episodes
a week you know or
the second episode is a bonus episode
we'll i'll have some other things
you know i don't know sports the about
shows it's just you know i'm just trying
to put out more content
uh if you go to the patreon you know
rachel and i made like a little personal
video and it's on our patreon and so
we're gonna start doing more things like
that so if you want extra content there
make sure you go there
you know be a member you know i i any
little support is great i appreciate it
so anyways let's get to that
real world advice from a grown
ass man i got a bunch of them this week
and they're all good
all right first one is how do i focus on
my craft
with a wife and three kids and a 12-hour
day work schedule should i
well i mean this is this is the struggle
that we all live with right how do we
manage our time you know that's really
what it's about how do we manage our
time
how do we focus on the things that are
important to us you know we just have to
do it
you know what i mean that's all i can
say it's it's actually the word you have
to manage your time
there's 24 hours in a day you have to
sleep you have to eat you know it's like
you just have to start to schedule you
have to plan
you know if things are important to you
you make time for the things that are
important to you
it's like of course we would want to
just be like hey i have this
hobby that i really love so can i just
ignore
everything else and just work on that no
you can't at a certain point because you
got a wife you got kids and you got a
job you got bills to pay
so you have to carve out some time for
yourself for those things that
make you happy the things that move you
that's the only way you can do that
you know it's like we have to just be
more responsible you know it's like we
have to you know
having a schedule is great if it's like
you wake up at eight you have a good
sleep schedule you have a good work
schedule you have to go like okay well
this is the day we're doing this and
this is the day we're doing that you
have date night with your wife you have
like okay i have to do this with my kids
every day
you know once you get into a routine and
schedule you could see the time and once
you see the schedule you go actually you
do have time could you go oh i could do
it on
at this time from this time to this time
i work on that
three times a week this is my time to
work on that everybody knows you're not
neglecting anyone because you go ugly
you have all these other times
this is the time for the kids honey this
is the time for you i need to take time
to do this
schedule it out in the same way that you
have a work schedule
you know your work says to you you have
to be at work from this time this time
this time this time and you somehow
excuse me i'm spitting all over the
place somehow you make it happen
you know because you it's scheduled so
schedule everything else in your life
too
that might help because i know this
person
and he's actually a great artist so
continue your work do your work
make time for it all right good luck
here's another one do you think constant
reflection is good
as a way to keep leveling up
constant reflection no i do not
i think that you reflect on things and
then you
you know you take some time to reflect
and then you have to take time to to
actually
do though do to do those things and move
on and my analogy is like football you
know
it's a nfl football you know what i mean
you practice all week
you play the game if you win the game
celebrate think
see reflect on here's the things we
could have done better
you know then you move on because you
have to start practicing for the next
game
if you lose the game again you reflect
you go this is what we did wrong this is
what we need to do better
take the disappointment you deal with it
and then you got to worry about the next
game
you got to put it behind you i think
that's how we should be in our lives too
i think you take time to reflect that
you have to take time to just live
you take time to just you know enjoy the
good moments in your life
you have to do that enjoy the good times
reflect
and then move on and then when it's time
to reflect again you take that time to
be like ooh
this is some things that happen how can
i change that how can i make it better
you know what i mean so i don't think
constant reflection is good
just uh you understand what i'm saying
i think you do all right what's the next
one here
this one's silly it's not silly it's
just should i be upfront about having
two baby mamas or drop the bomb after
two dates okay
first of all see this one is
is is is
it's strange because you know when you
go on a date with a stranger
they're a stranger so it's like at what
point
in a relationship should you tell
somebody some
super important information that's
eventually going to affect them
if the if this relationship continues
forward
like if you have a if you have a disease
you know some people that
like you know people that have hiv have
to deal with this people that have
herpes have to deal with this people
that have
you know what i mean you have like some
kind of a major thing in your life
that will affect this person do you tell
that person on the first date
i don't know i mean you know it's like
that's really personal it's like you
don't
even know how far you're gonna go but
then the other side of that is some
people go
you know they wait till four or five
days and they drop something on you then
you're like oh man why didn't you tell
me this ahead of time
because then your your response is well
because i thought you wouldn't want to
continue
you know but you know so i wanted you to
get to know me first and then i dropped
this information so i don't know if
there's a right or wrong answer
but i think you just have to feel it out
you know you feel it out
i don't know if on the first date you
want to tell some chick yo i i got
other kids i got kids and two baby mamas
you know like is that you okay with that
you might you know you might want to do
that you might want to drop that on
somebody on a first date but i think you
got to feel it out
depending on what they're talking about
too because we're all
we all got secrets we all got things
that we're not sharing
you know so i don't know if like on you
know you might be on a date and this
woman she might reveal some personal
stuff or you might get a
feel you might get a feel like hey i
actually comfortable with this person to
be like
well let me look this is some things
that are going on in my life
if you do that you have to be okay with
that person being like oh that's a
little bit too much for me
if they start to think like well i don't
know if i want to be involved in that
drama it just depends you have to just
feel it out
but but don't but i am not saying that
you keep it a secret
you can't do that you know i don't think
it's a good idea to keep a secret you
know
i think that you eventually it's
something that you want to reveal but
you want to reveal it
on your own terms when you're
comfortable
you know and i think that you should
also like what are you doing man
like maybe it's time for a condom or two
you know what i mean
like i don't don't get this one pregnant
or another one until it's
it's right so that's another that's a
whole other piece of advice
but uh you know look out for that but
good luck man
good luck in the dating life with a what
all that
baggage you got
okay here's another one i get this these
are the kind of questions i get a lot
this one right here i've been debating a
career change but my anxiety goes
through the roof
um you know i again i forgot to mention
straight off the bat listen i'm not a
doctor i'm not a psychologist i just
play one on a podcast i'm just giving
you guys advice but if you have some
real
problems you if you have some real
mental issues
you have like super bad anxiety
depression
things like that i encourage you to go
get help
i encourage you to exhaust your
resources to like
you know go go talk to someone therapy
is great you know
therapy it's not necessarily for
everyone but i i do recommend you try
you know and and date around you know if
you go to one therapist and if something
was funky about it go to another one but
i do
suggest you go because a therapist will
help you organize your thoughts and
feelings you know this expert
can see and recognize patterns and help
you figure it out help you go oh well
this is why i feel this way they're not
going to solve your problem but they're
going to help you
understand it so if you're having these
kind of you know
anxiety if it's just so crazy then you
have to ask yourself why do you have
anxiety you know like you know start to
like analyze it is what i'm saying about
this
you know i know you want to you know
when you're making a career change you
know
fear comes into play you know when i
hear this question
my mind goes to well i'm gonna make a
career change will i be able to pay my
rent will i be able to pay my bills
am i gonna be able to live the same
lifestyle am i gonna make it
am i gonna be good enough i mean these
are all things that come into your head
you feel doubt you feel that's what
anxiety that's
part of the anxiety so it's all about
planning you know it's all about that's
how you can like
make this career change if you have it
set up that you're gonna you
set yourself up to win make sure you're
knowledgeable at this career you're
gonna go into
make sure that you have savings in the
bank make sure that you have a plan
when you have all these kinds of things
in place to help you feel better about
this change you're going to make you're
not going to feel as anxious about it
but just like thinking about it
abstractly like oh do i want to do this
because all these things are in the back
of your head your mind is filling in the
gaps of all the things that can go wrong
set yourself up so you can see all the
things that can go right
believe in yourself attack it i think
you can do it
good luck all right here's one that uh i
i really appreciate this one let's talk
about gray hairs i just hit my 30s
and they're sprouting let them rock or
die them
you know i don't want to even be a
hypocrite about this
subject because but i'm in the
entertainment business so
there were times where i've done a movie
where the person was like hey we'd like
you to dye your hair
so i was a little insecure about it too
like having gray hair so i was like i
would dye my hair but at the same time i
would die
and i wouldn't keep up with it so i
would i would make it dark and then i
would just let it sit and then it would
just like the graze and stuff would come
out
but when quarantine hit and i just been
sitting in here so you know
i got this gray beard salt and pepper
beard now and you know i just
ah this is me now so i don't dye my hair
at all now
if if i do a part or something and
they're asking me to dye my hair i would
but i just like you know this is me
it's natural i feel good about it i am
who i am i'm you know i'm in my 40s and
it is what it is you know so you know if
you
feel looking young makes you feel better
or if you feel like you're not
you know getting responses from women
you know it's like what are the reasons
why you do it you know it's like you're
you're feeling bad about getting older
or you know you know so all these things
go through our head but
you know you just have to like be you i
mean that's what i would suggest but
i'm not going to be a hypocrite in beer
because i went through that too i went
through
of being like oh i don't like my i'm i
look old
i don't want to look old you know you
have all these feelings but
i i when i did this
i've gotten more responses you know i
especially females you know put messages
on the on the pictures and
they're just like oh i love this look
you know you'd be surprised you know
so it is what it is man you know there's
a sort of distinguished look you can
have
but i do understand the the feeling of
like oh can i just still feel young for
like a few more years
you know but try both you never know you
know but i again it's
it's a tough choice but make sure that
you know make sure you're doing it for
for the right reasons
you know if you are feeling insecure
about feeling a certain way
deal with see if you can deal with that
without dyeing your hair
you know and even if you just want to
dye your hair because you're like hey i
like different looks and i want to look
you know i'm doing something with my
hair and you want that makes you feel
good
you know then then do it but make sure
to make sure you understand
why you're doing what you're doing so
you can like
really own it you know what i mean
because even if you dye your hair you're
still going to feel
that insecurity because then you're
always going to be like oh is the gray
you have to diet again and it's a
constant upkeep and you're still going
to feel bad about yourself
so you need to work on feeling good
about yourself regardless
all right here's another one that i say
please reach out for some help you know
i want to lay in bed all day and not
interact with
society what can i do to get out of this
funk
well i mean i know this is this is just
one of those things man that i feel like
if this is becoming debilitating and you
feel like you can't
you really can't do it then i i really
recommend that you reach out and get
some help
but if you can't you know if you're
still
um feeling this way a start would be
exercising and and it doesn't mean like
you have to be in the gym you know pump
an iron no
it could just be like a morning walk and
it's something i'm starting to do i try
now every morning first thing i do when
i get up is i go let me get up
and let me go outside and get a walk
getting that sun in your eyes
and starting your day with that getting
your heart pumping there's something
about that
so i suggest that i know you don't want
to interact with people so just get some
headphones
get an audio book or a podcast like if
you're listening to my podcast this is
how i suggest you do it
wake up get your headphones put on some
you know comfortable gear
and just walk around your neighborhood
avoid people if you want
but walk for you and see how that starts
to make you feel
make sure you're getting the right
vitamins man make sure because people
aren't going outside and vitamin d is
important like people are not getting
enough vitamin d
so maybe you need to get some vitamin d
supplement like look up these kinds of
things make sure you get your vitamin c
make sure you're like eating right
because it could be like it could be
like because of this
being inside all the time it could be
affecting you in a way that you don't
realize
and this feeling of depression and stuff
it could be
enhanced by your lack of nutrition and
lack of
vitamin intake and all that kind of
stuff and you might be surprised you
might start feeling better
with just a little bit of activity and a
little bit of vitamins you know so
you know again i'm not a doctor or
anything like that i'm just telling you
from my own experience too because
this is something that's happened with
me like i got a blood test and i got
like
and it was like i went to next health
and i got this like
blood test and it was like well you know
you're this you're vitamin d deficient
you're b12 deficient it was like all
these things and i was like and
and this is how those things and you
look it up you go these are how those
things can affect you so
i know you feeling like this right now
and it might not all be just your fault
it might not all be like
oh it's in my head no it could be some
real physical things in your body that
are causing you to
feel this way and you can probably do
something about that but i would start
with like i said
working out start with working out start
with like
you know working on your on just little
things around yourself to make you feel
better you know
pick up a hobby um
clean up like there's a lot of things
that you could do
to make yourself feel better about your
personal space
when you start feeling good about that
that might encourage you to be like well
let me reach out
to do other things outside so i know
it's tough times right now
i know what this coronavirus and the
pandemic and the and the and
the stay-at-home orders and the the
social distancing and it's just making
us
all crazy and making us all feel anxious
and you know
on top of the things we were already
feeling even before that so i know it's
difficult
um and i i again if it becomes the thing
where you feel you
can't handle it i do recommend you reach
out for some help
but just try some of the things that i'm
saying but either way
i feel for you and good luck
here's another one i think we all have
this one um i'm having trouble saying no
when it comes to business
i've just went in too deep on two
projects
man you know boundaries
that's what this one's about you got to
have boundaries you know
if you're having trouble saying no it's
because you have
you're you don't want to let people down
or you don't want to
you know you want to you know be liked
or
it's like so many different reasons why
people are like this but
you got to have your boundaries man you
know sometimes you say
no you know people people will respect a
no
more than they will respect a yes
sometimes
because when people are asking you
something that they know is risky and
you say
no they can respect that they can be
like all right
they can be disappointed listen listen
it's okay to disappoint
people you could disappoint someone
because they wanted something from you
and you said hey looks like i can't do
that
but if they're going to be like you know
if they're going to be like well i'm
never talking to you again then
that's flimsy it's a flimsy relationship
anyway
it is okay for you to look at the pros
and cons
look weigh the odds look at the like you
know the risk assessment
take a look at all that stuff and if you
look at that and go this isn't a good
investment i i can't do this
it's okay to say no you have to be okay
with that
not only do you have to be okay with no
you have to be okay with
the guilt later you have to be okay with
that
that and that's just where we are even
on simple things like when somebody asks
you for money like my
this is what i say people say hey can i
have some money people like to ask like
this like to go
hey is it okay if i ask you for some
money
and my question my answer to that is
sure it's okay as long as it's okay if i
say no
that's on a grander scale when it comes
to like certain business things if
you're in too deep then you know you
know you should have said no
and it's okay like what did you get out
of that
nothing now you're now you're stressed
out about your situation
because you said you have trouble saying
no it's not about saying no you're
having trouble with
interpersonal skills you're having
trouble with dealing with people's
other people's emotions and feelings you
got to get over that [ __ ]
and move forward and make sure you're
making the right choice because they
will respect that
because sometimes people ask you stuff
because they don't respect you
they know they they know you're gonna
say yes so they so they take an
advantage
even if they're not doing it outwardly
just subconsciously people take
advantage of you like that so
be careful out there all right
boundaries
here's another one this is like a common
theme guys look at this
how do i motivate myself to continue
making music if i hate what i make
and myself like gee whiz
i mean i don't mean to laugh but it's
like it is what it is it's like come on
you can't
you know you know if you if you're like
if i hated my comedy
if i hated it i couldn't do it you know
i i just
i just couldn't do it so you know this
is just one of those things where you
have to look within yourself and be like
you know
am i good at this you know it's like you
have to start to love yourself and
appreciate the things that you do it's
like i i i have to make
for me in mind comedy i have to make
myself laugh
first if i don't think it's funny then
i can't go out there and do it now if i
think something's funny and no one else
laughs
but i thought it was funny sometimes i
still do it but but i
i gauge the response you know so if i do
something
i think it's funny and then people laugh
i go okay i was right they also think
it's funny
but you have to start with i have to
start with me so i know how hard it is
for
when you're insecure and you're
self-conscious about yourself and all
that
so you have to start by taking care of
yourself eating right exercising
organizing your life all those kinds of
things first get to know you get to love
you
and then you go with your music you know
make music that
you like to make like what do you like
to listen to on the radio what are the
music can you make that type of music
you know and that's what that's how you
have to go with it you know but it all
starts with like self you know
taking care of yourself loving yourself
you know
like i say work out organize your life
start there
and then branch out from there you know
you can't
have these kinds of feelings you have to
if you have these kinds of feelings you
have to attack those feelings
by asking yourself why do you feel the
way you feel
and then move on from there but you know
good luck man
i i i wish you the best you know i
really do wish you the best and
you know send me some of your music i'll
tell you if i like it or not
you know even if it's just it could be
garbage for all you know
and maybe instead of being instead of
being like
oh my god i'm the worst you just go well
that wasn't good
then you move on because every invention
nobody invented something like they just
invented it like this
that's the lucky people but most people
it's trial and error you know
you try you try you perfect that that um
that pursuit of perfection is actually
living like we're trying our way we're
throwing things out until we get it
right till it feels right
and that's how you do with your music
too you got to keep working on it till
you
keep tinkering until that magic happens
you know
but don't be so hard on yourself okay
come on man
all right we got that one we got that
one
all right wow i have so many of these i
might i have to cut it off go
save her for next week or save her for
wednesday right
is it bad i don't like my girls parents
i see a future with marriage and kids
is this a deal breaker i actually have a
video for this one
um a man sent my man sent me a video so
here it is
yo what's up eric this is alex
29 year old male and i got a question
man so i got a girl
but i don't like her parents and you
know uh
they're they're just kind of odd and
they're not the healthiest family out
there
and i plan to maybe have like something
further with this girl maybe thinking
about marriage and
kids and uh yeah man what do you think
about that is that a deal breaker
let me know peace all right so um
this is tough but i mean this is an
age-old thing like you're not marrying
her parents
you don't have to deal with them as much
as you think you actually do
you know it is what it is i mean like i
am used to not having a big family
i really am not i'm used to like it's
just me and it was just me and my mom
for a long time and then my stepdad
you know i'm estranged from a lot of
people in my family we don't really talk
and it's like
some part of me likes it like that you
know because it's like when you deal
with family it's a lot of hassle you
know
so now uh i have to deal with rachel's
family and she's got a huge family you
know i'm talking about grandma aunts
uncles you know and we're on this like
zoom call every week and like today
there was like a little
thing today you know it's like we
started talking about like
the coronavirus and then it got a little
it was getting a little bit like you
know
uh it just it's a heavy topic and then
one of her cousins was like you know i
don't think we should talk about this
because certain people are dominating
the conversation and i kind of took that
personal because i was like
would it be certain people if there's
nine people on the call you know you
you you don't say [ __ ] like certain
people you say
hey i think so-and-so and so-and-so is
like talking a lot and i think that
other people want to talk
you don't just put it ambiguously out
there when it's nine people on the damn
call you know what i mean so i took it
personal you know
and i was like this is an example of
like you have to deal with family you
know but
you just deal with it you know what i
mean so it's like i got upset i i kind
of left the room then rachel called me
back in and then we started talking
again
it kind of got smoothed over and her
family is very lovely people
but you know you're gonna have that
you're gonna have it where
you know the problem is is like you have
feelings for
your this loved one you have this this
your relationship
and it's like so everything connected to
that it don't feel the same
because because and it's not going to
because this is just that relationship
that closeness that bond you have with
that person it don't extend to everybody
in her family or everyone in yours
so you just have to know that you have
this this is important
and then you just tolerate the other
things you know you try to find the best
way to be like okay
this is not not always my cup of tea but
i don't have i just have to deal with
this on christmas and thanksgiving and
whatever
and here we are the most of the time you
you have to you deal with this person
this way
you know what i mean just suck it up man
you know it's like
it is what it is you know obviously you
care about her
and they are a part of it you know you
find ways to just
deal with things it's not always going
to be
the way you want it it's not always
going to be on under your terms
that's the deal when you get with
someone else you get with them and their
family
you know you just have to understand
that this is the level of the
relationship you have with the the
person
your girl and they are just like you
know they're there
you know you may learn to love them but
if you don't it's okay
it really is okay but it doesn't have to
be a deal breaker
you know so good luck brother all right
two more
okay how do you move on from the person
you thought was the one
without being scared well i mean this is
the idea that
like i don't believe in there's only one
i believe
that you connect with people and certain
people you connect
on a level that is just fantastic it's
explosive you know
you have sexual chemistry you have
personality chemistry and you just go oh
my god this feels so good this has to be
the one
no it's just the right now you just have
a great match with this person
i'm telling you you will get a match
with other people sometimes you just
have that thing too with someone you go
oh my god this is the greatest feeling
i've ever felt in my life and
then and then you compare that one to
every person you you meet after that
i'm telling you you have to be open you
have to just be open
and and you will see that you can
achieve that with
many many other people so don't be
scared like you're like okay if i don't
make this work
i have to move on because it wasn't
working so if it's not working and you
have these kind of doubts and
things that mess the relationship up
then by your own standard this ain't the
one
because that don't happen with the one
you know if that's how you feel about it
so don't be scared you know you just
move on
you know what i mean you just you just
accept the loss you have to deal with it
you know
like i said when you have that kind of
chemistry and good feelings with someone
you have this thing in your head where
you're like oh no i i don't want to lose
that
you're thinking about the good you're
like i can't lose that good thing it was
so good
and you feel like you're scared of what
that i'll never find that again and i'm
telling you that you can
find that again so just move on
that's the best thing you got to start
working out taking care of yourself
start you know doing some self-love some
self-care
and then get yourself back out there and
you'll be surprised you're going to meet
someone to be like oh my god this is the
one
and then you're going to start the cycle
all over again but don't be scared
don't be scared you're going to be fine
all right last one this is a good one
here
me and my father don't see eye to eye
and i don't know how to just
fix our bond i mean this is tough you
know we grow apart
you know it's like the thing happens
like with parents
is um
you know there comes a point in your
life where the the path that your
parents
want you to go on and the path that you
want to go on
sometimes they coincide sometimes they
go in the same direction and sometimes
they split
and at that point is when
you have to hope that the ideals
and things that your parents have taught
you
you're going to apply them to the life
that you want to live
you know and and hopefully you'll show
them that hey because of you i was able
to achieve this thing over here even
though i didn't do it the way you wanted
me to do
you know and so it sounds like you love
your dad and you want to
be close to your dad again so i think
you should talk to your dad about the
things that
what you remember what are the things
that you made you guys close like when i
think about my mom you know there was a
time
even with my mom and i we just like we
you know we were butting heads all the
time
but if i think back i i would talk to
her i would be like remember when we
used to play board
games together you know remember the
good times remember the little things
that like
that made you close talk about those
things with your dad
you know let you guys need to like you
know have like remember when
you know those kinds of things what are
the favorite foods you guys like
together like you know anchor yourselves
in
in in in the good times you know like is
there a restaurant you guys i'd like to
go to when times were good is there
certain food is there a certain movie
do you remember a movie you guys watched
together when you when you were younger
that really you guys both laughed and
had a good time
like for me when i think about my
stepdad i don't know i remember the day
that
my stepdad and i you know sort of like
really
like we had a great moment it was we
were
we were on the couch and white chicks
was on the the wayne's brothers movie
white chicks so we're sitting here we're
watching white chicks right
and we're just sitting on the couch
together didn't even know it was on like
we didn't like
we were watching it but we weren't
really watching it you know and then we
kind of started watching it
and then like stuff's happening and he
starts laughing right
and then i start to laugh but i don't
want to laugh you know because i'm
embarrassed to be laughing and he's like
he's embarrassed to be laughing
and then we just start hollering man
we're just
we we had the best time watching that
movie
just laughing about how dumb it was you
know because it was just
it was great that's a great movie for
that reason you know
and so that's a moment that no matter
what's happening in our lives if we
start to fight or whatever
i can think back to hey remember the
time we were laughing at white chicks
and that's something that we can like
share
and start to like laugh about you know
another time i remember my mom
they they weren't married yet and she
was trying to like get us close you know
so she sent
us to the hollywood bowl my mom had
these tickets to the hollywood bowl
to listen to classical music she loved
it she had like it was like a
it was like a subscription you know you
got like 10
tickets a year and you get to go to like
this the symphony so she didn't go and
she sent
us neither one of us wanted to be at
this damn symphony okay it was
you know and we so he's sitting there
i'm sitting there
and you know we're not really talking
we're listening to the music
and like he's falling asleep
i'm falling asleep but it's to kind of
fall asleep where you like you don't
want nobody
to know you feel i didn't want him to
know i'm falling asleep he didn't want
to know that he's fallen asleep
and then we both are falling asleep and
then we both kind of wake up and look at
each other
and we both start laughing because we
both knew
we were only here because my mom made us
come you know
and it was just kind of a nice moment to
be like hey i guess we're
kind of the same here you know and then
you know it just kind of like
it felt good to be like all right let's
just deal with this
for her you know like at that point we
could have just left and went and got
hamburgers and we would have been
we would have told her oh it was great
thanks for you know thanks for the
tickets but
you know it in a sense it worked what
she wanted she got out of it because we
were like
you know you know and then like you know
we're not we're not like super close
close you know what i mean but
i respect him especially that he takes
care of my mom right now with
with the dementia and so you know i have
a lot of love for him
you know so but anyways there's that
so i thank you for uh listening to these
two parts you know my little opening uh
spiel that i was talking about and real
world advice from a grown ass man
so stay tuned for what's next
you